fora tv' idea immersion
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation this will be the
third talk on the singularity the first
one was Bruce Sterling that one was
called the singularity your future is a
black hole and basically ding to some of
the over enthusiasm from people to the
counting on the singularity like kind of
a technological rapture that was going
to happen in their lifetime and then we
had recruits while who is basically bet
his reputation and career the
singularity is near and we had an
evening called Chris wilds law that was
very persuasive on the at least so far
technological determinism inevitability
of a major transformative and
irreversible event happening to humanity
in the next few decades
so how amazing to have the guy who
started the idea in the first place
and Vernon Vinci is a it's a science
fiction writer of ideas I just heard
from Peter Schwartz that he actually has
an idea box and out of the box comes
things like his current book rainbows
end and things like the very early and
very influential true names which
anticipated a whole lot of what
cyberspace became now did it anticipate
it because it thought about what could
happen or the people who made cyberspace
get influenced by that story that's the
kind of by play that goes on very often
with his kind of of writing and also his
kind of speaking which will here tonight
Vernor Vinge ii
[Applause]
thanks Stuart that's a very great
pleasure to be here in in preparing for
this talk I had the opportunity to go
back over the the talks in the series
that are already in place and its really
a marvelous resource that you and the
law now have put together and certainly
very pleased to hear what Alexander is
talking about for the where it's going
now so my talk here has the title as you
see what if the singularity does not
happen just for the record I should
define what I mean what I mean by the
technological singularity and that's
that it seems to be plausible that with
technology we can in the fairly near
future create or become creatures that
surpass humans events beyond such an
event which is what I use the term
technological singularity for or is
unimaginable to us as opera is to a
flatworm well taking that as - as being
what the idea is it makes almost by
definition discussing discussing long
term thinking to be an impractical
impractical thing and so when Stuart
originally suggested that I come and
give a talk about the law now I was
almost bewildered but then I thought
that there is something that science
fiction writers do and what good
scenario planners do and that is whether
or not they believe that a particular
scenario was a likely one or not good
science fiction writers and good
scenario planners think about
alternatives to their scenarios so it's
in that spirit
that I am approaching this talk by the
way I'm also making one other assumption
and that is that we don't figure it out
how to get faster-than-light space
travel just for the sake of people who
are are surfing in on this talk perhaps
later on the web out of context I want
to make it clear that I still regard the
singularity as the most likely non
catastrophic outcome for our near future
there are perhaps ways of stopping the
singularity but the only surefire ways I
know of would be to blow up the world
you know before we before we make it
happen there are all sorts of plausible
catastrophic scenarios about this
century and I recommend Martin Rees is
our final hour for some insight into
those for the most part I'll try to
steer clear of you know final blackout
type scenarios here in in their own way
those are as unusable for scenario
planners as are the scenarios that
involve the singularity although in a
much more pessimistic way so I want to
talk about a scenario that hopefully it
is not one of the catastrophic ones and
that for some reason does not have the
singularity in it and so I've come up
with a the beginning of this scenario is
how the lack of the singularity or the
singularity fail failure might might
have might appear so I have a bunch of
symptoms here which is a common thing
that's done in scenario planning in fact
one of the more important things is to
think about the symptoms that might
happen if the scenario was going to go
in in in some particular way and the
particular reason probably not not
pointed to definitively until after the
fact you know 50 years from now when you
have to right now
say why was obvious all along that
sinclair couldn't happen that sort of
thing I come up with these prospective
symptoms in this scenario we never
really figure out how to put the parts
together we get the hardware power but
we never figure it out how to put the
parts together if you are of a more
mystical bench you might say we never
found the soul in the hardware as the
years progressed these symptoms for such
a scenario might be that software
creation continued to be the province of
software engineering you know using Java
to solve or to try to solve ever vaster
problems ever vaster right ever vaster
of software projects and finding that
software projects are are failing in
very very spectacular ways already
software failures are are really strange
interesting things large with large ones
many large project failures if you have
a government budget you just can keep
throwing money at it to the point where
you can eventually eventually proclaim
some sort of victory
there have been software failures that
have been so large that even though the
entities that were funding them had deep
pockets in the end they really just had
to give up and walk away and say yep we
weren't able to make it work and that by
itself is an interesting with a large
class of failure some of these failures
also might be interesting in other ways
and that is if the people who always
claim say these terrible things about
the limitations of computer programs in
in this world where everything stays
software engineering I could imagine
some very peculiar failures especially
in large automation projects where a
large control projects for people
attempt total automation you can imagine
human flight controllers they
occasionally make mistakes that cause
aircraft to run into each other I could
imagine a bug in a fully automatic
aircraft controller that could actually
cause an n way
which is you know that's really
superhuman in a certain way so anyway if
we if we generally got such an era where
the largest of these automation projects
failed one might actually imagine
manufacturers backing away from their
improvement schedules which is really
what makes in an economic sense is the
is the step that where the actual of
slope of Moore's law for the next year
or two is determined and if that
happened we might actually see a failure
of Moore's law that wasn't so much
because it couldn't Bend be done but
just because some of the economic drive
for it being done had been it had been
removed by the failure of those of
software engineering if that happened
then one could imagine eventually the
basic research would itself also level
off both both because of funding lack of
funding and also because of failure to
have the hardware that could support the
type of research that would push
Hardware project further along so what
you might get is a situation where
hardware improvements continued for the
longest time on the simplest forms of of
hardware for structures are very regular
things like large memory systems stuff
like that and in the end we have some
extraordinarily good audio-visual
entertainment products noting post
singular and some very very very large
databases but without software to
properly exploit them if this was how
things actually worked out it most
people would probably not be surprised
in that case if the power of strong AI
the promise of strong AI was not
fulfilled and in the same circumstances
there actually are other associated
things that many of us hopeful for like
nanotech general assemblers and stuff
like that that also could probably also
elude
development so it's not surprising that
altogether the early years of this time
would come to be called the age of
failed dreams I want to talk about the
the characteristics outside of these
sort of technical characteristics of
this age of failed dreams by the way
about a year ago I brought this sort of
general notion up with Hans Moravec
talking to him about the possibilities
that you know we thought of the singular
didn't happen he had a very interesting
reaction he was he said that would be so
remarkable I mean something that is
obviously so inevitable if it didn't
happen my god that might be the most
interesting thing of all to try to
figure out why it didn't happen there's
some fundamental thing about the
universe was not not the way we had
thought it obviously was well I don't I
I don't go there in this I just say we
have those symptoms and eventually you
know the the people who have been so
enthusiastic about this get old and and
they're the old farts and it's a it's
clearly passed say you know there's a
singularity on the other hand some of
the consequences of the situation might
seem comforting there's a thing called
Edelson z-- law says the number of
important insights that are not being
made is increasing exponentially with
time and actually I see this as just
evidence of what happens if if you're
trying to confront the production of
information and in some cases something
like knowledge with a merely human minds
that you will see something like a dulce
--nz law well if if these trends
actually slow down then one could
imagine that there would be time for us
to begin to catch up although in some
cases
such as just the accumulation of
bioscience and really cute oh by ology
information you know about metabolic
pathways and and genomics and
comparative genomics and stuff like that
the databases could probably continue to
fill faster and faster and we would we
would just be falling further and
further behind which actually would fit
with it with the notion of us remaining
eternally clueless about some
fundamental understanding of how things
go there's also the possibility that
might warm the cockles of some software
managers and that is if things slow down
on the hardware front then finally we go
back and do all that crummy software
right I really don't think that would
happen although in the long run if we're
talking about thousands of years was
getting ahead of myself but in the long
run I think probably in the fullness of
time there would be people who would try
it you could imagine if you were given
several centuries you might be able to
redo all the legacy software and my
prediction is that all that does is set
up and set up a new layer in the mid and
pile upon which you will you will pile
still more garbage and in centuries
later they will go back and maybe if
they're foolish enough think about
trying to rationalize that less
comforting is that I think in this
scenario that I'm talking about
humanity's chances for surviving the
century would actually be more dubious
than they would be otherwise our
environmental threats that people are
talking about so much they would still
exist and to me
actually more serious our warfare
threats nowadays we are most most of us
I think properly so are terrified by the
notion of nuclear terrorism against
cities but compare that to what happened
say but what didn't happen between 1970
and 1990 when there were nation states
who are talking about exploding tens of
thousands of nuclear weapons many of
them over cities
in a space of a few days and sort of a
cooperative endeavor to wipe everybody
else a return to mutually assured
destruction type schemes it seems to me
it's entirely plausible and it is
something that goes hand-in-hand with
whatever external or environmental
issues are going on environmental
problems that might merely cause a lot
of misery if they are hooked up with
national interests that actually are
attached to military machines of
especially of a sort than if they're
involved mutual assured destruction
schemes that's really a plausible
civilization killer
want to talk about envisioning various
possibilities for the long now that
would stretch out after the age of
failed dreams so I'm going to assume
that somehow we managed to survive the
the 21st century and we're now in a
position to talk about things happening
over a very long period of time and I
want to talk about some some scenarios
that that actually cover a lot of
different possibilities and I have to I
have two or three you know separate
little diagrams for the for the
different scenarios
typically in diagrams like this you see
people who graph something like
population as a function of time but
what I want to do is to graph some
aspect of technology as at the
relationship event to population size
and here's here's an example of the sort
of plot that this is this is a for the
situation in you know in our world up to
the present time situation so far all of
these pictures are going to be hour long
now on earth well this looks like a lot
of pictures I've drawn over the years
for the singularity right and a lot of
pictures you've probably seen for the
you notice how steep things are getting
to the right if you look at actually
what's what are the axes this is not a
diagram of the sort that that is adverse
advertising some eminent singular sort
of event and so I want to talk about the
axes a little bit first of all time is
not explicit in the axes the horizontal
axis is population size it's not time
its population size the vertical axis I
wanted it to be some aspect of
technology and so you know I thought
about that actually I thought about it
too much maybe so maybe I mean I could
graph the total effluent or the effluent
per person or something like that have
that be the vertical but there's several
reasons for not doing that one is it
would have been too hard for me to
research numbers so in the end I decided
to just go for maximum power source and
by that I mean I'm almost in a definite
way as a discrete power source
what is the maximum power source that
that was available to our civilization
when its size was a size indicated by
population number on the horizontal axis
so if I if I had if I had really good
you know perfect knowledge of the past
the way to generate this to curve would
be to just for every year from 50,000 BC
on for that year look up and see what
was the maximum discrete power source
that humans had had usable access to so
that would give me the the vertical
coordinate of that of a point on the
graph in the horizontal coordinate would
be what the human population of the
earth was at that time and as you go
along on this graph I you know I spent
an afternoon with Wikipedia or Google
and looked around and one thing you
notice about this sort of graph is that
it actually can talk about a long period
of time and there are things on the
graph that may be separated by
distance on the blue line and actually
are not very much time and we'll see
more of that later and there are some
places that look quite close that are
actually separated by a lot of time so
that the lower-left there's 50,000 BC I
didn't try to chase it back further
because basically a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
are beginning to wonder whether you're
talking about human beings anymore
but 50 thousand I said okay we have just
you know the power of a person and as
they gradually coordinate with each
other maybe more people it's sort of a
matter of humor to talk about dropping
big rocks on one's enemies partly
because it's sort of hard for me to work
that out in two units of power but I
decided to put it in there just for the
heck of it if I had it to do over again
I wouldn't have put horses at 6000 BC it
would have been ox and at about 8,000 BC
which I think would have actually have a
little bit more horsepower than horses
you'll notice that as we go along the
the graph is rising presumably because
we're gaining these devices together but
still into manipulatable units one
interesting thing is about how how
steady and Roatan and robust things seem
to be for instance the Black Death is
scarcely a little leftward match it
actually did decrease in absolute
numbers the population so that's why i
illustrated it actually with a little
diversion to the left didn't change the
vertical coordinates at all
18:50 begin to get nautical steam
engines that could give you a megawatt
of power and then right now or in our
era the largest power stations are about
13 gigawatts now if it isn't clear
already let me go to this up right hand
corner where things are beginning to
look like they're going straight up
let's suppose that we manage to
stabilize civilisation which actually
looks like we have a shot at it in the
next century suppose manage to stabilize
situation just as a stabilized
population and there was still some
modest improvement in the size of power
stations that we built well in that case
this this graph the
would go straight up it doesn't mean
that anything unknowable has happened
it's just that this is not the graph of
a function it's just the relationship
between the maximum available power at a
given population size and you will in
the later diagrams you'll see think
situations where it actually can you
know wrap around in various in in
various in various ways so I I like this
sort of diagram because it's going to
allow me to look at the entire human era
from say 50,000 years before now to
50,000 years after now after after now
in other words the whole human long now
is visible all all at all at once which
seems sort of appropriate for this sort
of a venue now that was a situation
right now as I say it doesn't look too
exciting but I want to look at three
possibilities or scenarios in their own
right for for this sort of situation
here's the first one
ah I said I wasn't gonna kill everybody
sorry about that I want it I want to
have one where everybody gets killed it
it illustrates the it illustrates the
things about this way of looking at at
the relationship of population and
technology it also illustrates things
about where the length of the curve may
be misleading for instance it looks like
we got a little bit beyond the present
and then advice about the dangers of
mutually assured destruction strategies
were not heated and and we got it back
into such an event and we had a major
spasm type em ad war and so here on the
diagram where it says a single afternoon
of madness this is say this is a few
hours or maybe a few days that takes the
pop human population down to about 10
million and then since this is this is
an extinction scenario it might take a
little bit longer to push us back
although all the way to extinction I'm
it may seem that I have a thing about
nuclear warfare actually nuclear warfare
is one of those tried and not tried and
true it's one of those one of those
things where there are lots of things
known about the devices they can scale
way up and the thing about em ad is you
actually are getting very large numbers
of people in very large amounts of
resources that are being dedicated to
figuring out how to cause this sort of
extreme damage and there is a sort of
magical logic about EM ad that keeps
raising the threshold of acceptable
damage and two levels of destruction
that would are enormous ly higher than
what people thought about what they were
going to do to begin with so it's hard
to think of any threat where a genius is
so explicitly aimed at our own
destruction what about other forms of
technology being brought in to help kill
people off that that could be true too I
mean it is it is sort of interesting to
imagine what could be done with diseases
if your goal was to really
make them something that just in
particular evaded what the current
technology was for curing diseases I
haven't tried to tried to think too much
about that but one could imagine that
all their I think Martin Rees made an
interesting point in his book which was
he was talking about some of these some
of these existential threats that some
people worry about a lot like gray goo
or or other things that involve really a
technological tour de force to get
within shouting distance of being able
to do the threat and his point was that
he didn't think you really have to worry
about that because basically long before
you managed to bill the technological
house of cards that could support these
really cool ways of you know blowing
everything up and killing everybody off
long before you get to that level the
mundane versions of of destruction will
probably by accident or or malignant
intent of some sort another they will
cause disasters that will either wipe
everybody out or or wipe civilization
out so I think that that sort of thing
is I'm concentrating on this one version
of it but that's something to keep in
mind that actually we are in in a
situation where if you put your mind to
it you probably could cause an
existential threat to civilization so
that was the first one a return to
madness and anybody who's lived through
the era of the fate of the earth and the
tea taps report has has been exposed to
all sorts of that stuff like that I'm
actually quite skeptical skeptical about
these two preceding references but for
the reasons that I've I talked about
well the slide was up on the board it's
something that I think in principle
could be as destructive as as some
people have feared in the past ah the
next one the Golden Age this is sort of
to sort of make up for my cheating on
not well not killing everybody the
Golden Age was a non-singular scenario
where I tried to you know be as nice as
I could and I hear the first part of the
graph is as before here you can see it's
definitely not a function of population
size I'll have some others where it's
obviously not a function of you know not
a graph that represents a function of
power source we're at the year or 2000
or so now and in this in this version
here I have what I've labeled a peaceful
ascent into a Golden Age which lasts
about a thousand years you'll notice
that there is some technological
improvement in power sources in that
time and and actually the population
Falls to about 300 excuse me to about 3
billion so this is the sort of world
that I think a lot of people would it
would kind of hope for think that it
that it might happen it means that
somehow we managed to avoid the
existential threats that everybody is
worrying about and and so I think that a
lot of time and effort of the law now at
least in the near term for the law now
is to think how to have this peaceful
ascent into a golden age and I think
there actually are a lot of trends that
make that plausible I see a plasticity
in the human psyche that that can
actually cause large numbers of people
to to behave in very different ways over
short periods of time I think the
leveling off a population growth in at
the at the turn of the century here has
been an example of that that when you
give people hope and information and
communication it's amazing how fast they
start behaving with a wisdom that
exceeds the elites and this is something
that I makes me the most optimistic
about the present time that the
government the the governments of the
largest countries realize that their
national wealth depends more than
anything on having large numbers
of relatively happy creative
communicating educated people that's
where the wealth is these governments
may still want to go on and play their
usual games but there is that notion
that they're going to have to at least
create the illusion of freedom if
they're going to maintain this resource
there's only one problem with that and
that is for them and that is that once
you hook up millions and hundreds of
millions of people that are educated and
can talk to each other they develop a
certain understanding of what's going on
and there are hundreds of thousands
probably millions of them out there that
are better educated and smarter than the
captains of of state and the and the
advisers of the captains of state there
is just a complete mismatch of
intellectual horsepower there and so
providing the people with the illusion
of freedom would would probably have to
generate in a better imitation of
freedom than has ever existed in human
history
just looking at what such I I don't
really like the term populism much but I
kind of apply it here sort of a new
populism it's a new populism in which
the participants in the populism have
self-interest but it is such a wide it's
such a wide horizon and it's so well
informed that it can actually be
mistaken for tolerance and such people
working together in large numbers I
think can produce miraculous things in
1995 as somebody had told to describe
the wikipedia to me and told me Oh what
it has demonstrably done to date
whatever you may think about the future
of Wikipedia but what it is demonstrable
done to date I would have said you
should take out a pencil and paper in an
envelope and do some simple arithmetic
and you see this is [ __ ] and
furthermore you will see that you don't
really understand the destructive
impulse of people who like to break
things that are beautiful and so I am
just so I
I'm just so happy that that that to me
this has been a miraculous development
how successful this is and that's why
although I regard the Golden Age as as
probably too optimistic because on earth
there are there are just there are just
dangers and accidents that can happen
it's sort of like having even if even if
everybody are people of goodwill if
they're standing around in a room filled
with dynamite of various sorts it's a
dangerous situation but I actually
regard this golden age one is it's not
it's it's not an idol or an impossible
dream it would be something that could
happen and figuring out how to make it
happen or how to make deviations from
this ideal how to make those deviations
less destructive and certainly how to
avoid extinction that's a very very
realistic goal the part that says along
a good time that's kind of my quirkiness
coming out there I just tried to imagine
what would happen after that after we
get down our population down to three
billion and we're all having a great
time and all of that there is still the
long now out there
as I understand it Stewart we're talking
at least 10,000 years
well 15 I you know sort of hazy little
blob out there at the end of this long
good time I was thinking that you know I
was gonna label at 50,000 because that's
why when it goes from minus 50,000 to
plus 50,000 that's what I really wanted
to say and I can't anymore say what
would happen after that and I can I then
then I could say what does it really
mean before 50,000 years ago no matter
how well we do fifty thousand years from
now is far enough in the future just
looking at biological time and and
things like that that even in the
happiest scenarios
I really wouldn't expect the human race
to be be around as human race after that
point and if you think about it that's
what in the 20s and 30s and 40s when
people talked about progress and
scientific project
progress they were quite happy to talk
about good things like that happening
good unimaginably good things happening
like that way far away it's only in the
late 20th century when people started
talking about it happening before the
audience gets to retirement age that all
of a sudden everybody gets really
nervous about the prospect so there is
no way that I can see that as live as
there's there's no way that I can see
that one could expect a long good time
for humans on earth to go on forever so
that's where I put that sort of little
hazy we went on to become something
better balloon there at the at the end
of this Golden Age and you'll notice
that I also had the population gradually
increasing up up to actually probably I
got my logarithms a little bit long it
looks it looks like I got it increasing
up to at least 50 or 60 billion on earth
and I decided to just do that for the
for the fun of it apparently uh because
I've been so impressed by what large
population does to things like the
Wikipedia where you you have experts
about topics of arbitrarily precise and
specialized nature all talking to each
other and and all being creative so I
kind of felt that perhaps there's an
argument that having a very large
population if you can keep the other
issues and a high standard of living
it might actually be quite a quite a
good thing and so that's what I showed
there in fact if we're really talking
about 50 thousand years in the future on
the scale of this diagram for all we
know these folks actually did some
experimentation or repair to four or
five thousand years they might drive it
down as they did here to three billion
or maybe they pushed it up to like 60 or
70 billion and instead add us to that's
too high in the end and then as sort of
a group consensus it brought it back to
something that was a little bit lower
it's not really possible to see here but
in such a long now there would be some
room for that sort of experimentation
I have actually have besides the the
trends that I that I've talked about
that might make such a golden age
plausible I actually have a substantive
suggestion that maybe a little bit at
odds with some of the other talks that
I've seen in the series and here's a
suggestion policy suggestion don't want
you to take this as special pleading the
policy suggestion is that old people are
good for the future of humanity young
old people are good for the future of
humanity so that Pro longevity research
may be one of the most important
undertakings for the long-term safety of
the human race and when I see most
people talk about Pro longevity I think
actually Ray Kurzweil has talked about
the objections he gets to people talking
about Pro longevity some of the some of
the objections are well some of them
sections are just very foolish like well
everybody everybody would be senile then
you know that's not that's not what Pro
longevity is meant to that's why I said
young old people and other people say
that they you know they would just dead
in progress and that actually is very a
very common one and and well who knows I
mean we don't have any 500 year people
admitting to being 500 years old we
don't have any 500 year old people who
actually are still you know young and
vibrant we don't know what they would be
like but actually I think that there is
a lot of reason to believe that having a
significant percentage of the population
that was young and very old would be
very very healthy for the long now one
analogy would be just the what having
very old tribe members did I think it
really helps tribes in the Paleolithic
to have members that are very old you
know like 40 years old that this gave a
scale of understanding about you know
cycles and stuff personal understanding
and what things were like during the
last dry season
and I see no reason why the same thing
wouldn't be true on longer scale at the
same time if one talks about
self-interest it's one thing to have
self-interest in one's great-great
great-great great-great-great
grandchildren and it's another thing it
may be a lot more common to some people
to have a knowledge of their own
self-interest with the notion that they
are going to be around after the next
election or the next stock market report
or the next 500 years
so if we manage to do that besides
having people that have a long
perspective on the future a long
prospective view when they think about
the future eventually we would have
people that actually have a lot of
experience about the very far past and
this example sort of undercuts my point
but it you know the story there's this
old codger says you know we tried that
in aught four it didn't work then and
it's not going to work now
and I could imagine that too happening
in the future only this guy is not
talking about 1904 or 2004 he's talking
about the four thousands and he wouldn't
be talking like an old codger either in
a you know he could look like a fairly
young guy and he might be absolutely
wrong but the thing is in the law now
having people who actually embody the
parts of the law now is it seems to me
almost certainly a very positive thing
well now we get to the scenario that if
we if we don't get a say a singularity a
serial for the long now on earth that I
think is in some form the most likely
although I as with all of these
scenarios I've chosen to make it as
extreme you know to make it be an
extreme case and I call it the The Wheel
of Time which probably gives it away but
now you know what all the white space in
that diagram was for and as I was
toiling away with [ __ ] you know and
trying to make my little Bezier curves
work on this thing I was sort of
imagining as a science fiction writer
each of those tortuous turns must really
mean I mean there's really a separate
story or sequence of stories about each
of those some of them may have been
nuclear Wars others may it may have been
some really bad plague or an
environmental thing they got totally out
of hand and some of that would have
changed the actual shape I generally
went for the shape that sort of
resonates with a rather dramatic loss of
population of fallen technology and then
crawling back up and so you'll notice
that somewhere in the future we get week
we have here three little turns of the
wheel now notice those little turns of
the wheel percentage-wise are much
larger than the Black Death was if these
things happen fast they would be
extraordinary disasters even these first
little three here and then something
really bad happened and here you see an
excursion that takes us down to a world
population of 10 million and and not
even and not even devices as powerful as
naval you know good naval steam engines
that one eye you can see these guys
tried to climb back up what can we know
about the amplitude of these cycles if
you look at the diagram you know I'm I'm
making statements about how how far I
think the population fell and and in a
sense how far the technology fell but um
what would be the amplitude I don't
think anybody knows although I think
it's worth speculating about and and
besides besides the question of how many
people would die and how low technology
would go there's there's the question of
how long would it take to track around
the the the cycle and how high you could
get once you came back you notice in
these first little turnarounds that each
time the population ended up being not
quite as big as it was at the maximum
before and but we got up to higher
levels of power I don't know that that
is true in the 60s and 70s and 80s there
were people like Harrison brown
the challenge of man's future who had
this theory that once she went through
an event like this that what it took to
make technology was an infrastructure
that once destroyed could not be rebuilt
because we had consumed so much of the
resource universe of the world in in
getting there to begin with and so that
if we came back at all it would be in
some crippled state I think that's very
untrue and John McCarthy is here in the
audience and I think he has a website
that gives all sorts of good good
arguments why it might not be true that
that actually resources can be can be
accessed and will exist under under all
sorts of circumstances it's always seen
to me start as strange to talk about
mineral minerals or ores being harder to
access when you have all these cities
left over from the last time around
fossil fuels might be have gone away in
a way that's counter balanced by the
fact that I think we probably have left
more libraries more accessible libraries
and there are dinosaur fossils
that's not nice sure that's not
literally true but if you look at all
the different ways that we have that we
have that we have saved our information
in some cases deliberately so it could
be accessed in the future in some cases
not but it doesn't matter a flooded
library of paper books that that then
froze are dried out or something like
that some of them might be totally
destroyed and some of them might be
eminently resuscitate able so in this
sort of Wheel of Time scenario your
archaeologists to the long haul would be
the enduring heroes of civilization in
fact science as such might actually
accept except when you get to the to the
top that things go new science is not
being is not being done except in a very
sort of unhappy way you know new science
that actually turns out to be that the
archaeologists just hadn't found that
page yet but we
without running some experiments we
don't know also we don't know from this
diagram
really how dreadful this situation is
because we don't know the times take
what happens after this very bad
excursion we almost looks like somebody
was trying for a golden age here and
they didn't quite make it they got up to
here and something bad happened to them
I apparently speculated there was a war
because I say dropping big rocks on
one's enemies you know asteroid sized
rocks in this case but it may have been
that we got hit by a big rock or some
other sort of disaster in other words
life on Earth is a dangerous thing and
of what happened here and we may have
had a very long good run here made it in
tens of thousands of years we eventually
came to a bet almost came to a bad end
and you notice the notation here that we
we almost lost it on that one but this
is the happy this is wheels time so
these guys eventually make it back up so
we go round and round like that and
despite the fact that there could be
thousands of years that are quite good
there is there are existential threats
here and there existential threats that
we really don't
we really can't quantify because we are
the only experiment so say sir we really
don't know much about these cycles
except that I think it's plausible that
the worst of them could kill everyone on
earth so how to deal with the deadliest
of uncertainties if you look at this
talk I keep saying who knows no one
knows I don't think anyone really knows
you know the answer to a lot of these
sorts of questions and I've made kind of
a list here how dangerous is mad really
in fact
mad got us through the 20th century
alive that sounds like a good thing we
just we just don't know what how much of
an existential threat is posed by
environmental change there are some
people who think they know I'm not sure
whether I believe them how fast we can
recover from major catastrophes
how closest technology to becoming so
good that instead of talking about
nation-state madness that just people
were having a bad hair day could kill
everybody I mean if you want to talk
about really high technology is that
sort of thing
feasible and then the other questions I
raised like having like what is it good
to have lots of young old people so we
really there's so many of those things
that we don't know because we're
essentially running one experiment and
actually have this tremendous respect
for scenario planning there is another
tool that is wonderful if you have it
and that is simply broad experience so
broad experience means you know just
just having other people who have tried
out certain things and can tell you it's
a really bad idea and you may even know
people have been killed because they
tried some stupid thing and it got them
killed at a civilization level the only
examples we have compared to our
examples that are not comparable if they
had nothing like our technology they had
they had nothing like our communication
abilities and stuff like that so they're
really not pure examples and beyond that
there are lots of things about what's
safe and what's not safe that you really
need hundreds or thousands of examples
the Framingham Heart Study is kind of a
good example there are things about diet
and exercise that just watching your
parents or your even your grandparents
is not enough to really get an idea of
statistically what how risky certain
behaviors are the Framingham so
Framingham study can provide that but
how do you get that when you're talking
about a situation when you have where
you have only the one case now I think
everybody who's been looking at these
diagrams and the titles you notice that
the upper right hand corner of each of
the diagrams it says the long now our
long now on earth well the obvious thing
that I'm leading up to here is that self
sufficient offers settlement
our best hope for long-term survival not
of life on Earth although I will argue
that it actually would improve the
prospects of our having having the
Golden Age but for the survival of the
human race and I am so pleased that
people like impressive people like
Hawking and Dyson and Reese are talking
about that have brought that back to the
center of discussion and people have
been doing that for decades Stewart
Brand it is a book on the space colonies
in this in the 70s and having this come
back to be a center of discussion I
think is actually quite important and
and I think it's actually very very
important to in particular the law now I
also want to say that again this is not
a way to avoid the singularity I think
it's a singularity can happen it is
going to happen and it would happen in a
singularity situation too but along with
all sorts of other things we don't don't
know about what are some objections to
having talking about really serious
self-sufficient settlements in space the
first one is which I get very seriously
from very serious people that chasing
after safety in space would distract us
from solving our life and death problems
on earth I you know I I think the
situation on earth is sufficiently
dangerous that a moral stand on this
issue is you know against space colonies
is is very very dubious chasing after
space assumes the real estate has not
already taken that's actually a
possibility that in the singularity are
two of the most important practical
mysteries that we face a real space
program would be too dangerous in the
short term ah that's when I don't hear
very often I see actually some virtue in
that you remember in that last slide
things blew up because people were
dropping big rocks and their enemies a
real a real space program meaning cheap
access to space is very close to
providing a WMD capability this may be
one of those very rare circuit
stances normally when people talk about
things they want to do they're dangerous
in the long term but there's some
gratification in the short term here you
have something that might conceive it
well not that I think is very good for
the long term it might add somewhat to
risks on the short term that is kind of
a peculiar situation I don't think the
the existential risk is that great but I
wanted to put it on the list and then
there are the practical objections
there's no other place in the solar
system to support human civilization and
the stars are too far well being a child
of 1950s science fiction I could go on
about this for another hour so but let
me just say the stars are not too far
even at even at even at relatively low
speeds if you're a long now type of
person and in fact I thought this was
cool Robert Heinlein had this book time
for the stars
because the long-range foundation is a
nonprofit organization that funds
expensive long-term projects for the
benefit of mankind so Danny and Stuart
are still out there and I I think this
is just a perfect a perfect fit now I
really in some ways as far as propaganda
the real thing here is I think I'm
talking about a real supposed face
program and that's not what we have I've
that we started with launch costs five
to ten thousand dollars a kilogram as
far as I can tell the vision for Space
Exploration which is currently the
manned spaceflight initiative of the
administration still in is talking about
five to ten thousand dollars per
kilogram just to low-earth orbit this is
this makes any talk of humans in space a
doubly gold-plated sham for two reasons
one of course that it proposes pitiful
limitations on the delivered payloads
and the other is that
it means the payloads themselves have to
be so reliable and so compact that they
are enormous ly expensive now I'm
addressing this to humans in space but
actually because I'm not you know I'm
not trying to alienate the
astrophysicists and other forms of
astronomers and stuff like that but I
really the the astrophysicists the
cosmologists they've also been mugged by
these two these two gold-plated reasons
first of all that they spent and they
have to spend enormous amounts of money
for their projects in space which then
may be defunded and you know at a
political whim and the other thing is
that if the launch costs were lower just
think if you're involved in these
programs what you could do with $500 a
pound to low-earth orbit or five hundred
five hundred or thousand dollars a
kilogram to low-earth orbit what you
could do with that I think in many cases
an argument could be made that even with
those still relatively high expenses you
could do things like make space
telescopes that are cheaper large ones
that are cheaper than what you could do
on the ground because at those prices
what you could put in space is stuff
that could use things like laser
positioning and certain insects and
synthetic aperture that would probably
be orders of magnitude simpler and
cheaper than trying to do that on the
ground so I think it's something even
the even the robot space people should
think about it especially the scientists
I am talking about here just for the
human based program in space and that's
why I think people all through the 20th
century average people understood how
important it was in a gut way how
important it was to have humanity into
space and I think their their enthusiasm
has been abused and because I think that
getting humankind into space is so
important to long-term survival I would
urge that we reject any major humans in
space initiative that does not have as
the prerequisite the goal for much
cheaper access to space well I think
I'll in there
I think this is where the law central to
central to a serious long now survival
of the human race thanks
Vernor thank you that was fantastic
unlike many of our speakers you actually
spent some time cruising through the
previous speakers into summaries and so
on I'm curious what you found there and
how any of that connected to what you
were talking about tonight the the the
discussion of prolong javadi i reviewed
where i could see of that Kevin Kelly's
discussion about the future of science
that seemed to me tied in with the
golden age possibilities overall I of
them as being very much the sort of
planning that one would hope to go in to
the Golden Age version for instance the
cities there you've had two on city and
modern cities this version that I'm that
I am is probably you know in a way it's
it's it is it is less detail oriented
and it's more on trying to bring space
and in particular colonization at
interstellar ranges if you notice that
that really means you want to have
thousands of civilization hundreds of
civilizations you want to have separate
histories you want to be able to run
framing hams that are actually about
existential civilization issues here's a
question from Ryan Brant Brian grant
back there waiting is surpassing humans
well-defined who can measure what human
potential is if much of our automation
effort goes into augmenting our
capabilities he points out that all
points on an exponential feel the same
ah that was pointed out well not not the
last part about exponential but that
that general point was made to be my
haunts more back in 1983 on a riverboat
in Pittsburgh so that you know this this
stuff about the singularity that's cool
I believe it he said but then he said
you know if we're augmenting our
intelligence as we go along and if you
are writing if your intellect is writing
that exponential then the event
you're talking about Verner with a
singularity are not unintelligible at
all and then apology says and I intend
to ride that exponential so I agree with
that point it's pal it's probably the
the most mellow way of looking at the
singularity although actually I have I
have at least one friend that says he
doesn't trust people you know people are
no damn good people people have hundreds
of tens of millions of years of bloody
baggage they're carrying around back
here so I much rather trust a machine to
be much more mellow and in fact he said
if you're going to give these powers to
anybody there's only one that I would
trust and he patted himself on the other
chest well yeah there's a version of
sort of the more of xserve there's a few
of them there behind walls of either
sort of advanced version you can
understand what's going on there or you
know we're being kept from knowing that
because it's too dangerous
Derek Percy Derek Percy's we're out
there how could one best dart against
the world like the scenario proposed but
with singularity confined labs
situations such as military industrial
sites and kept from general knowledge
for the indeterminate future is it was
Wikipedia made that kind of thing
impossible now or is that the way it
might actually go there only a few get
to I think that yeah I I think actually
there's all sorts of different ways to
getting to the singularity in fact
that's one reason why it's a little bit
hard for me to talk about the
alternatives that the the the general
people plus networks plus large
databases that's that's one the classic
AI is it is another which I think is is
you know people don't think about very
much right now going to have so much
spectacular neat things going on with
the internet but all of these things
insert all of those two things and
several others I think are quite
possible and in some of them could
originate in in quite localized ways in
which case the main question is how fast
how how fast is the transition it seems
like a lot of things come down to how
fast is the transition yes I I
characterize the hard takeoffs and soft
takeoffs a soft takeoff
like twenty or thirty years which is
faster than any is as fast as any of the
transformations we normally talk about
hard takeoff is a hundred hours or so
and I think a hundred hours a transition
is quite plausible if one reasons it by
analogy that when humans came along what
was there before innovated but very
slowly in an afternoon a human could
innovate at Paleolithic human could
innovate on a scale that would take even
even evolved adaptation it could it was
even maybe a thousand times faster than
that so we don't have much to go on
about what post singular would be like
but I think the notion that it might be
very very fast is plausible and I call
it a hard take-off because it would be
more like an explosion than it would be
like progress
is there any way such a herd take off
and not be tremendously selective with
some folk and this is the rapture kinda
oh yeah hard takeoff is more scary to me
than a soft takeoff a soft takeoff is
it's so long that you could imagine in
fact that the infrastructure and the
whole society that's supporting it is
growing along with it so even if they in
other words at each stage they're able
to see what the next stage is going to
be like even if they're not quite
participating but in sort of mellowing
it and in getting some consensus about
what they want to do and and being able
to correct mning more power for
themselves and so they're correcting
where things seem to be seem to be going
awry so a soft takeoff it's quite
plausible to me that it's be quite
mellow a hard takeoff it might turn out
to be mellow but frankly a the scariest
hard takeoff would be one that comes in
a military arms race where the the spies
on each side with the Manhattan Project
are reacting on a shorter and shorter
time scale until you get to the point
where they realize by eight o'clock
tomorrow morning the enemy is going to
have it you know end of game so we have
to take some chances to get to get to it
by 7:35 and as you come down towards
something like that that sounds very
scary well there's a couple things that
come with pay so one of them is
and in those fast changes the hard
takeoff mistakes can cascade whereas
with change is slow enough to watch
itself and make less mistakes can
correct themselves and so it sounds like
a hard takeoff is a real invitation to
catastrophe it and we don't know what's
going on inside of it you know there
might be there might be entities inside
of it that are doing their best to make
it make it be good but yeah the soft
takeoff Park takes of I think what a lot
of people have faith in the abilities of
society as a whole and smart people in
societies to talk things over intented
you know make things make things correct
for where there were misunderstandings
maybe there's a moralistic work around
here that could be introduced which is
it's kind of the deal and good armies
the officers always eat after the troops
and they eat what the troops eat so
suppose high tech people and scientific
movers and shakers said we're not going
anywhere if everybody can't come I think
that's hard to enforce but it of course
both in force and make possible but like
all ethical concerns it's a it's a goal
and I think it's I think it's actually a
goal that with with certain amount of
effort would not not because of any any
regulation or anything but it actually
it could come close to attainment just
because of the fact that what I said
about the broad nature of people in
general that the more that they are
plugged in in the more that they are
educated and the more that they are
participating that that is that that is
a power for good so just the you know
the general spread of cellphones I think
has been the this extraordinarily
positive thing that sort of thing I
think has the effect of doing what what
you use
you suggested in general having a policy
that says we're not going to go forward
until we brought everybody up I think
that is that sort of thing that unless
unless it can be done some somehow was
like what I said about the cellphones
it's not it's not something that can be
acted upon except by stopping and
allowing some bad guys maybe to have no
regard for such notions for them to push
ahead yeah I would give a couple already
existing examples when you keep
mentioning is Wikipedia and Jimmy Wales
has spoken here to this group who takes
a very strong ethical moral position
which is that all knowledge should be
available to all people in all languages
for free and Google has a similar
version of that well these are two huge
success stories based on basically
include everybody or forget it
oh I actually I don't I I agree with
everything except your last sentence and
in other words include the option for
everybody how's that they've created a
situation and the principle that you
related to me is I don't see how that's
connected with a notion we're not going
to go forward until we can bring
everybody forward but it is what they
have done is they've said these things
about information should be out there
people should be able to try and we have
the power not not by stopping anything
we have the power to give people that
power so it's not it's not that we're
stopping at all it's a positive state
now a negative statement accurate here's
a question from Yvonne Burgess right
here have you considered a scenario
where the vertical axis maximum power
source somehow becomes irrelevant non
determinant is superseded by some other
factor your science fiction mother yes
what other factor might do that I I had
I had a hard time with that vertical
axis I I wanted basically something
about technology also I wanted to be
something that I could look ups you know
more or less hard numbers for and after
about three tries some of them really
gruesome my I won't tell you what some
of the ones I came up with I did tell
you about the effluent I had one that
was worse than that and I did want a
vertical access that was something to do
with technology so if the question is of
something that's not related
technology I think I'd have even greater
trouble making a chart out of it but you
know making any sort of numerical things
about something might be something maybe
level of education per you know the
average average level of education that
would have been a cool one although I
regard that is very close to technology
here's a invitation to a science fiction
plot from Quinn Norton where's Quinn
Norton
over there can you see a scene or
scenario where some humans go post
singularity some have an isolated pool
of golden age and the rest are caught in
the wheel of time can you talk about a
world with all three ah space is deep
captain yeah they certainly could be a
world of all three also I could imagine
a very checkered board and saying Manuka
neck tivity that you could have a
situation where the third world first
world divided becomes a matter of meters
you know instead of separate continents
and this actually should be a big
motivation to again to bring everybody
forward because it is a very a dangerous
situation some people I think again
honset had had had the notion of a plan
for a soft takeoff in which in the early
years the ai's need people a lot i think
they'll always need people for a very
long time but they need to people a lot
and so basically people didn't pay taxes
anymore why just need people people are
orthogonal ii robust
in the same way in the same row throg
annealer robust nice or not no no we are
throw phagon ly robust to them to them
well i see so it's sort of like bacteria
we're like anybody know seriously talks
about killing all the bacteria I don't
like those pesky bacteria or virus we're
gonna kill all of them in this room you
know that could be done but even if it
even if it could be done without
immediately killing us it would be very
destructive of our interests so there
are
there are things I don't think we can
pull the plug on the a is once they
happen but there are disasters that
would be much more immediately
destructive that them to us and we are
something that can exist when all the
phone lines are down not all of us can
exist or not many of us will go away but
we are actually we are actually a type
of creature that can can live in the
wild now there are there is
infrastructure we need which is why it's
good not to destroy that but we can we
we could bring them back from situations
where they were totally gone and so I
think I think a wise AI would would
would really want to have us it's not
exactly like a backup system but it is
something it's something like a
resurrection system so we need to hustle
through the period of stupid a eyes find
us problematic and get on to the really
smart really wise really connected a
eyes who realize that we're the wildtype
backups like four hours later that'll be
one of your weird afternoons they use be
go okay here's a question from John
McCarthy right here of concerning space
what about other countries your critique
was pretty much focused on the temporary
US dominance certainly if we want to
look at any sort of longer time horizon
that the the particular nations become
as irrelevant as the particular nations
who you know brought the United States
into into existence in the short term I
I think there's a very good chance that
one of the most likely ways we are going
to get a real space program is just
military reasons that the the the the
use of the US as made of space has has
depended on it being very very expensive
so expensive that everybody else is
priced out of the market and gives us
very great
powers and many simple solutions in fact
it's made life dangerously too easy from
a military perspective because they're
they're sort of weak links there and
once you have antagonists that are
playing in that same arena then you
begin to get then you then you get begin
to get a coevolution or an arms race
there and at that point being able to
hoist large payloads becomes a quite
important and quite dangerous in the
near term but international competition
towards space if we survived it might be
something that we would look back on
from our numerous civilizations across
the Stars and saying well yeah that
worked out for the best there's a
question from Scott it looks like
Nazarian this is a real science fiction
writers question what's the human
imagination indefinitely postponed a
true singularity because we are
endlessly imagining the future of
something like it in other words instead
of bothering to actually create a future
we it's just as much fun to keep on
imagining it
there are people out there or trying to
make money though and there's not enough
money in science fiction to say oh gee
there's not enough money in science
fiction there's there are reasons for
wanting to do these things that don't
really have anything to do with the
imagination of with the imagination of
science fiction writers or other sorts
of dreamers I think that people don't
realize that an awful lot of the
technological establishment is working
diligently toward the singularity any
any time you have guys talking about
human machine interfaces I don't mean
like this you know I just mean like a
better GUI or or wearable computers or
any of any of these things or higher
bandwidth on communications and easier
to use all of this is sort of
progressing in that direction and it's
the sort of thing that can't really be
it is not really recognized by a lot of
a lot of those people now I got a
impression from by the way you're the
first speaker to give the simultaneous
text we were offering
as big deal is gonna come out with these
videos and you have it like way ahead of
the curve here if it makes it makes up
for the troglodytic in 1970s graphics
but the sense I got both from your
written in his book in the speech of was
that environmental issues
sounded like including climate change
were not huge on your radar I just don't
know I mean I said there were a lot of
things we don't know we don't know
actually I have opinions about those
things but I think it's important that's
what I'm probably for here I mean there
are there are if you want my opinion I
think it's clear that we are operating
on a scale that can cause changes in
climate I think it's also clear that the
whole process is sort of a dynamically
chaotic process in fact the analogy that
I use is the whole situation reminds me
a little bit about the parable of the of
the blind tribe and their wise man
mm-hmm tribe of blind people and they
have this wise man who's also blind and
one morning he brings them all together
into their tiny camp says I have
something very important to tell you my
friends I've thought about this a lot
I'm a wise man and we are living at the
edge of a precipice run for your lives
so we have these so panic about climate
changes not the weight response
we have all sorts of possibly
existential threats we don't know what
they are I think you know this doesn't
mean we don't think about them but I'm
saying it's certainly at the at the
point that I'm coming at it is no matter
how good we are we are going to have
imponderable we are going to have deadly
uncertainties being trapped in a closet
as we are locked in a closet with a lot
of people who not necessarily friends of
each others and they're armed with
knives and some of them have hand
grenades and machine guns and some of
them are crazy and then there's
environmental things in that same thing
that's not that's that that by itself is
is is a is a prescription for disaster
and so at a higher at a meta level the
notion that if you're talking about the
law now the thing is to get other
running instances at a distance broad
broadness of experiences you say well it
sounds like that one of the things
you're looking for from the singularity
which you're still pretty much counting
on
despite the exploration of tonight of
alternatives is that it is the kind of
thing that can make problems like
climate change irrelevant yeah it puts
us stuff in a different stage and it
probably would make that irrelevant it's
not clear quite all that it would it
would do so in fact if this were a
policy discussion and we're trying to
say should we have a singularity or not
to me that's an entirely different thing
I don't think we have any choice on that
it may not happen it may happen it's not
something a committee is going to decide
so from that standpoint I don't think
talking about having a singularity or
not having a singularity you know is a
meaningful policy discussion but if it
did happen then talking about how to
move up toward it safely watching for
symptoms that it is happening and trying
to make it happen safely that's that is
reasonable and what's going but planning
for what's what you're going to do
afterwards is probably is probably not
not too much you have there except you
could leave notes for your superhuman so
it's sounding like the accelerating
technologies would be best employed for
trivial things first like entertainment
where if they fail it's not bad rather
than the first thing you tried to do is
fix the atmosphere right planet ah I
don't think we're going to have that
much choice about about what different
people apply these things for so I know
yeah you will because there's different
scales one person pretty easily can
apply it to entertainment to apply it to
the atmosphere would take more than one
person and so there's a scale and a pace
difference that happens even with the
same two
yes by engaging different scales of
problem I think if I were talking about
policy issues for related to the single
area to make it safer or not what you
just said is is the category of thing I
think another category of thing is is
talking about stuff that might tend to
make it be a soft takeoff talking about
things that empower the designers so
that they that they actually are better
able to talk about what they are are
doing and I think there's some hope you
know along those lines something that it
would not be good is a military AI you
know a secret military I a I thing would
be especially bad if there was a second
secret military AII thing that somebody
else was doing because they would
accelerate each other into oblivion or
they would be wise each other in a bad
way or well I I think just as with the
Manhattan Project it would be a sieve
and both both sides would be watching
the others very carefully and and that
there would it would be a type of
acceleration there if I were going to
write a nightmare story that would be
the you know the arms race that that
that ends at 8:30 tomorrow morning how
possible do you think large-scale
secrecy is in the world now and to come
my guess is that it's not very possible
at if you mean demands on from whom so
III think that there are organizations
that will probably be able to keep you
and me from knowing what's going on
inside those organizations for how long
for long enough for it for it to cause a
serious harm I think that for those
organizations to keep things secret from
their peers may be may be hard and and
also I think it's it's also true in a
slightly more mellow what you know if
you if you what I said about being able
to keep the secret there's a very tight
thing at a larger scale I think the one
of the more happier things about this
madcap rush toward
total insidious surveillance is to the
extent that we can make it symmetrical
it is much less dangerous and it is much
less harmful so I'm actually very I read
a vyd Bryn's greatest contributions has
been the transparent society stuff and I
realize yes I'm and I realized that for
me and I think most people it at first
glance there's this terrible oh my god
they would know about you know fill in
the blanks and I think that actually for
a few years if we achieved really a lot
of symmetric knowledge of you know of
what's going on it would be a very bumpy
few years and then and then afterwards
it would be pretty much the way it is
now except some of the worst villains
would either be off the map or else they
would or else they would be productive
citizens I mean if they were smart they
would just be productive citizens it's
easier the shortest path yeah well it's
interesting because this kind of sort of
omniscience total knowledge has been and
the various religions reserved God but
not reserved you know is it believing
whatever God knows your innermost
thoughts including the icky ones and you
have to deal with that and now you're
proposing a world in which there's no
extraterrestrial deity doing this it is
our very own selves knowing each other's
innermost thoughts and what's been
pointed out to me is how in in in some
situations small-town situations how
terrible that can be one thing about
small towns though there also are people
with deep dark secrets that no one knows
about because they're you know they're
they are tied to a bed out in a small
cabin you know in the middle of their
farm and so III think that actually the
the people who talk talk about how bad
you know how bad they talk about the
transparency is being illustrated by
small towns I think they are wrong I
they they're right about that but social
wide transparency I think would be would
be good because one thing that you
besides the
that you know the terrible thing I just
mentioned about somebody you know locked
away that that if everybody knew it
actually you begin you begin to get a
certain amount of tolerance because
around along the range of thousands and
millions of people there's a lot of
stuff going on and the question really
is what is really intolerable you decide
what other things are entitle becomes a
much smaller list you wrote a book
recently enough you probably remember
called rainbows in yes in which various
permutations of this kind of
transparency and other things are
wonderfully played out what's your sense
of how what goes on or rainbows and
which I really recommend everybody here
relates to what you've been talking
about tonight
Oh rainbows and was cleverly written so
that you can't tell whether it's weather
so you can debate whether it's on the
singularity track or not okay there are
several characters in rainbows and in
fact there's a spectrum of characters of
greater or lesser super humanity
depending on how melodramatic you think
the author is is it what sort of
melodramatic license the author is
taking with his fiction it is where I
think things could well be by say 2025
and if you look at it from the
singularity thing it is just before
things become so seriously strange that
nobody can pretend that the singularity
is not under way if you want to say that
singularity is not happening there it's
a little bit harder but it it would be
it illustrates what I was saying about
how even if the government's the
government's realize that they have to
put up with people because the people
are what makes the wealth and this story
could be could be considered to be on
the well into that where it doesn't it's
actually a rather dystopian statist
story the thing is there's all this
stuff going on that it doesn't matter
they haven't overthrown the government
they're just saying you know you the
government you have you thing you know I
do it well we'll we'll pretend like
you're running the country and then
there's this other stuff going this is
neo libertarianism I can just see now a
crypto Liberator
well you haven't written the sequel yet
one understands that you might well yes
so you don't have to commit anything by
speculating where you might go with a
sequel to rainbows and I should suggest
that in rainbows in there are a couple
of characters who wouldn't starts to
suspect by the end of the book may well
be a is who live on the net and are
pretending to be humans what happens
next
yes you have illustrated the problem
with writing a story that has all sorts
of intriguing things like that tapping
tapping that or showing where it was
going wood is going to be very hard
actually I do really have some ideas
pardon there are multiple scenarios yeah
oh yeah okay one multiple scenario is
IIIi think that it we may find that
there is room for different sorts of
intelligence and if you look at the
story there are actually different sorts
of possibly superhuman intelligence in
fact there's different sorts of
intelligence that may not be at human
level like the mice and it would be kind
of cool if what you got in into the
singularity was a whole group of
different things some some of them more
physically powerful some of them faster
acting some of them slower acting and
some of them made me subhuman but
they're getting better and they have
their claws near the infrastructure and
that I really think that one thing that
you might see in such an era is a
departure from the genetically
self-interested you know forms of
xenophobia and a genocide genocide it's
not quite the word when in evolution but
that we've had in the past that when it
comes down to things that are advanced
in us so that it's just the mode of
thought and preserving the mode of
thought and taking the parts that are
good and using those modes of thought
for later structures when it gets up to
that level I I think we might see the
was it nature bloody in tooth and claw
we might see that sort of mellow out
because that's really not import
that that in fact is just the metazoan
message about evolution that involves
having very high threshold between
critters that are competing and you eat
them up where you cut their throats or
your or whatever and that's how you
advance if the thresholds between AI
identity and consciousness get to be
lower than I think the whole situation
with competition becomes much more of a
of a of a lateral thing and and one like
a bacteria yeah more like back to accept
still there's perhaps more hierarchy
more hierarchy possible than there is
hierarchy with bacteria but more
hierarchy than is generally associated
with bacterium Riis not bringing up
bacterias kevin kelly and paul hawken
and I have been discussing horizontal
gene transfer which is much despised by
my fellow on for our medalists and I
think it's just swell because bacteria
do it all the time and in fact we're now
again I do environmentalists transfer
between kingdoms and so you know
intellectually that'll probably the
cases well here's a question without a
name relating to Teilhard de Chardin
whose Omega Point involves basically an
ultimate the human convergence evolution
to a real religious and conscious
breakthrough it's a kind of a
singularity and your vision seems to
focus mainly on technology how do those
relate if at all oh I think they
probably do relate I there's a lot of
things growing up that I only that I
really wasn't aware of but I was the
fish but I was a fish swimming in the
water of those ideas how hard was a guy
that I actually ever read his stuff but
I was very aware of it you know in in
the popular stuff that in the 1950s and
reading about it and I thought it was
seriously cool so my mother she brought
me up on teller and yeah that's I I
think there must be some way that this
can all make technological sense you
know and yep well with the omega point
and view and dinnertime approaching I
think we've had an evening of it and
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you